hey L it's great to be here thank you
yeah you have been to several of our
classes which we uh greatly appreciate
but we've never done this before yeah
it's been an honor to have a chance to
to to come and cover a case study that
you you do very well here um on
entrepreneurship and uh I've always
enjoyed it I've been super impressed
with the people that and the questions
that that have come up in these classes
well let's get started by just talking a
little bit about how you got you know
not how you got here today but you know
how you got to this place in your life
so you went to you grew up uh in Canada
yep now I used to Toronto and where'd
you go to school went to school called
Dartmouth College yeah it's an awesome
school anybody know D somebody's got to
somebody's got to do a shout out and
tell us how else how your path LED you
to here so yeah I um so I I grew up in a
really small town east of Toronto um and
I think I was looking for a school that
also had a small town fi so Dartmouth
felt right for me um and when I entered
Dartmouth in ' 89 as a freshman it was
one of a very small number of schools
that standardized on Max and everybody
had to email when they came in I'm sure
Stanford was probably at that stage too
but um because of the you know the
ubiquity of Max and in the undergrad uh
population there's a pretty steady
pipeline of undergrads that got
recruited out to Apple so um I had an
opportunity to to work as an intern at
Apple in the summer 92 um and then uh
you know my first job at Dartmouth was
working in the dining hall you know to
to help pay down the student debt and um
it certainly was a much more fun job
when Apple sent me back with a bunch of
computers to to write code for them so I
did that my senior year and then came
back back out here full-time when I
graduated 93 um so so my you know I
wasn't you know founding a company until
many years after I got to the to the Bay
Area but so 20 years ago you came this
way did did you ever think you'd be here
today as CEO of New Relic and having
started a another company that was sold
successfully I mean did you ever what
did you think you'd be 20 years later oh
I mean you have dreams but then you know
it's you also have um doubts and and and
all sorts of things um so no I don't I I
certainly you I didn't think i' I I
belonged as a student I had serious
imposter syndrome so yeah um so no I
never imagined so you saw yourself as an
engineer but then how did you all of a
sudden start a company this is Wy and
then um yeah so I found a company called
how did that happen from being an
engineer so so I've I've Loved building
software um ever since I I discovered my
first computer and that was in uh my my
parents gave me a computer in 82 it had
3 kilobytes of ram um so what is that
like one 1000th of a single MP3 song um
and um but I discovered the what you
know what I wanted to do for the rest of
my life I mean the joy of creating
software was just something I I couldn't
resist doing so um it was easy for me to
pick a major at Dartmouth although I
also minored in in Latin and classical
studies and I guess that kind of is part
of the story might be that I I had a
broad set of interest and I wasn't just
you know I love the art side of creating
software not just the science side of
um so so you know I couldn't believe
that I could get paid to do this you
know to write code and build software
and so it was an easy yes to to say to
come out here and work for Apple you
know that's a really significant point
because we celebrate that here at
Stanford I think we use the term
humanist engineer yeah I mean that there
is this dichotomy saying well you're
either an engineer or a humanist and you
can't be both do you agree with that or
just no I think the very best um
Engineers really do have an instinct for
what people want an empathy for the user
um even if you're just designing
something like an API there's someone
who is using that API um and so um
that's why I think liberal arts
educations are great for developing the
whole set of skills that are involved in
creating building great software um and
of course you need to learn how to work
with people too if you're if you're
working on a team no matter what your
role is so I'm a big believer in that
big believer in that all right um so Wy
so you're you're a founder of a compy
yeah so so I um I had an interest in in
startups and thought I'd love to to get
involved in in a startup and and you
know tried many ideas as mental
exercises but um in in January of uh or
sorry December of 97 an idea hit me um
that I really it just hit me like a ton
of breaks and it's very technical idea
but the idea was um at that time Java
was this new technology that um was very
early in its uh adoption but I I was a
huge fan of java and thought it could be
transformational to how people built
software and today is Java is by far the
number one programming language um for
modern software but at that time it was
this viewed as this toy and the idea I
had was what if I could make Java
software self- diagnostic what if I
could make any Java application report
about itself while it runs so that
whoever whoever built or ran that
software could understand how it's
performing in production and fix
problems in production so that idea was
the Genesis of a company that I founded
called Wy technology in '98 um and uh
and long story short that was a
wonderful learning experience I had no
management experience when I started the
company so I was learning a ton on the
job but it grew to about 350 employees
about 55 million in revenues and it was
acquired in 06 um for 375 Million by CA
um and we that that company created a
category software called application
Performance Management um so it was a
wonderful experience and a great you
know a great you know great outcome for
all the stakeholders but I I I learned a
ton along the way well we have a a laugh
about this on occasion a Harvard
Business School wrote a case about his
experience at
Wy uh and it's super popular it's taught
a number of Business Schools it's taught
in all kinds of schools here at Stanford
and and even within here in the
engineering school um I suspect that one
of many of you will end up doing that
case at some point because I can think
of besides myself I can think of two or
three other professors who use that as
uh one of the anchor tenants of their uh
courses and so it's it's always a kick
to to teach it there's so many angles in
the in the case um first of all was
about how you've what lessons you've
learned about leadership I mean to go
from being
a you know inventor I mean person who
pursues patents to all of a sudden
creating a whole company around it and
what it means to become a CEO of such a
thing uh that's a thread yeah the guts
of the story was the transition from me
as founding CEO to um it was we decided
to to bring on a a professional who had
you know with management experience that
could lead the company the next stage
and really gets into the emotional side
of what's it like to to you know give up
the CEO role that you're you're still
very connected to your company and you
want it to succeed and trying to find
the right person um and um you know I
learned an enormous amount in that
process um and you know to jump to a
point that I think is worth dwelling on
like the difference between now I am
serving as CEO of New Relic and we're uh
New Relic is my second company in many
ways I think of it as um if I didn't
sell Wy and were to do it all over again
what would I do to try to make a company
that could last decades or or longer um
as an independent company that had a
real impact and that company's New Relic
but the question is you know having had
two runs at this one as founder CEO to
about 50 employees and one running it
through to to this point at least uh how
many people this new okay 600 600 today
600 today uh up from about 375 in
January it's just like I'm far beyond
the ability to memorize the names and
all that stuff so I'm always like hey
how's it going I should know your name
but but I know you work for me um but uh
anyway so so the I think the biggest
change for me personally was my first
time around I really felt compelled as
CEO to be U more of a domain expert in
everything and um to in effect to be
someone I'm not I I I felt like you know
I had this image of what a CEO should do
how they should spend their time and how
they should behave and I tried to make
myself fit that mold and I it was it was
a terrible mistake um you know I'm not
one to sit in um cly review meetings and
and um and or or pipeline review
meetings or to um or to uh you know uh
you know drill through the financials um
I I I I have a great appreciation for
all those things um but you know at the
end of day I love building products and
I love um and and and I love uh
recruiting amazing people to to join me
on the journey and so this time around
uh I was very thoughtful about how I
spent my time and how I Define my role
and I was very very proactive on
recruiting incredibly senior capable
people that could be CEOs of other
companies to do the parts of my CEO job
that I don't want to do for example uh I
I have a table in my office it has six
chairs around it if there's a meeting
that that can't fit around that table I
don't go to it because I'm not one to go
to meetings I'd rather be building
software and and or I'd rather be making
decisions and and I found if I'm in a
group meeting with 20 people I'm either
if I say anything I'm going to
overweight the meeting and if I if I if
I don't participate then i' I've just
got too short an attention span to
actually stay engaged in the meetings so
um I have really smart people that um
run the larger meetings um and and but
do other parts of like leading the
company that that you know I'm not
passionate about not particular good at
so I want to follow this thread but I
want to give people context I I want to
explain
just how impressive New Relic is
um go to the website you it's fine just
bring it up and look at the numbers
we're talking about so what do you do at
we're a software analytics company so
what does that mean um we collect uh
billions of metrics from live software
applications um to tell the people who
build software and run software what
it's doing how it's running what people
are doing to make that software better
so uh the most profound example of us
you know having an impact was last uh
late last November when healthcare.gov
was having those Front Page News
challenges just keeping the site running
they had no idea what was going on or
why the site was down so often and so
slow um New Relic was called in and
within a week um the software we
provided told um hundreds of people
working working on healthcare.gov
exactly what they need to do to fix it
and immediately the response times went
down the site availability went up and
people could get health insurance um but
we do that for uh over 10,000 companies
companies like Airbnb and um Nike and
Disney and um uh New York Times and you
know it just spans virtually every
vertical um but uh but if you think
about every every business is a software
business yeah um so so every business
needs to make sure their software works
and that's what we do is we help them
make sure software Delights their
customers yeah I I saw something on the
site um getting ready for this that
about data that it's I forget the
tagline but it it forget it now we're
all data nerds yeah data nerds yeah they
had two meanings to me and all about
data but also about culture which we'll
talk about in a bit yeah I mean the
other thing that we wanted to do at New
Relic was celebrate the Builders of
software so in my first uh company at Wy
um the the software developers as a
constituent um the conventional wisdom
was you don't don't want to sell to that
that crew they're you know they have you
know small budgets and um not that much
influence but if you think about where
the world is going today the people who
build the software are really the people
who are changing the world in many ways
um and so we want to build a product
that Army an army of people love and use
and so over 300,000 people developers
have used a product this year um and
they're an incredible um if they're a
hard crowd to please um because since
they build software for a living it's
kind of like a if you're an actor and
your entire audience is actors they can
sort of pick all the little things that
might be wrong with the software so but
if you do please them they're a very U
loyal bunch and they self- reference so
um so we celebrate the data nerds and uh
and so we've got these data nerd
t-shirts we give out for people who try
the software and um and and and a in a
campaign and and if you just think about
it data is basically fundamental to
every business decision and uh and and
we the data we collect is from the guts
of the software and that's the that's
that's the guts of your business so we
think there's a massive opportunity
there so now that you've gotten to know
him a little bit I get to ask him this
question where did the new new name New
Relic come from uh so I I you know I had
a prototype and an idea and I thought it
was time to uh start you know put put a
company around this and not knowing
whether or not it would become a real
company but I need it to incorporate so
on short notice I had to come up with a
name and I didn't have any bright ideas
so I just typed my name Lou CER and an
anagram Builder and uh you can you can
Google anagram Builders and type your
own name in why you do that now it could
be your name of your company someday I
think I think another anim of my name is
Ren lice or something like that R Li
would be a pretty good name that's not
quite got the same no new really so I I
I'm waited for you to get to know him a
little bit before I asked that uh
because I always get a kick out of that
uh piece of information that he's so
humble he's also
audacious he's really audacious he want
you want to make new
a huge company yeah I mean there's I
mean you're not just hoping somebody
buys you someday you're doing this for a
whole another thing then what would I do
you know my my wife would just kick me
out again to start another company
because I'd drive her crazy um so no I
um I built one company and sold it and I
have no regrets how that went but
um because I talked about my role and
how I spend my time I've thoughtfully
tried to design my role in my company so
that I love my Monday so much and my
employees love their Monday so much
there's nothing we'd rather be doing I
think this is one of the problems with a
lot of the companies in Silicon Valley
they think um look you can put up with a
job you don't like for a few years
because it'll all work out in the end
when these options might be worth
something and then we can start living
the life we want to live I think that's
just the wrong way to look at it I think
we should sort of you know basically if
you structure your work life so it's
you're doing what you love and you're
doing what people you admire and respect
and love then why would you want to do
anything else yeah um and so this is the
last job job I ever want to have and I
want to be doing it for a lot longer um
I love to build software I still get to
do that I still I'm doing it with but I
I you know I love building you know
where did this philosophy come from
though what what did that motivate was
that something from your parents or was
it something you just have developed
over your professional life I mean it
seems so simple on one level but you
know I don't it's just I guess this
common sense that you know in life so
many times if all you're doing is
chasing the outcome rather than really
focusing on on you know why what you do
matters um so the outcome might be some
Financial La is the only reason it
matters I mean like who really gets
excited about that um um and and by the
way those companies where the only
reason why um people come and work on a
Monday is because there's some pot of
gold at the other end and that's the
only thing keeping them in the company
those companies don't weather storms
very well right and startups will we
will have to weather storms um so um you
know it was just this thoughtful like uh
approach of
new relics you know currently at a point
where it's generated more for for for my
family than we'll ever um need so um
it's not about that it's about um it's
about what can we do to to to to build a
company that you know makes hopefully
thousands of employees love their
Mondays makes our customers uh
successful with the software they run um
and uh and and you know and just helps
me personally begin continue to to learn
and grow yeah well let's jump thank you
for that and because it sounds simple
but it's I don't understand why it's not
practiced more and that's we live in a
place where it's pretty seductive to
just look at you know the the shallow
things uh know the shallow things I mean
like it's not that but you know just
just the easy to describe things like
share price yeah right and and just
don't let that take your eye at the ball
like you know you got to ask the
question why does why are you doing what
you do well so having with my wonderful
colleagues built out an entrepreneurship
and Innovation Education Center in the
engineering school we come from the
engineer ing mindset so I think we share
that common background but then it isn't
just about the money it's about changing
in some cases saving the world well I
yeah and I don't want to I don't want us
to put ourselves on too high a pedestal
but I have been deeply thoughtful about
you know why does what New Relic do
matters I mean we make software a little
bit faster right so um it's taking a
while to really think deeply on it but
here's my best answer to it um I think
the most precious thing we have on this
planet is time the most precious thing
we have is time and thank you for
spending some time in this room um but
you know it's possible to make more
money it's not possible to create more
time right and so people
spend uh uh young people spend up to six
hours a day in front of software so if
you think about managing that time
making the most of that time um Life's
too short for bad software Life's too
short for crappy software and that's why
when when you wait six seconds for that
page to load you know it seems like the
mother of all first world problems why
you why are you so frustrated during
those 6 seconds when you know it should
take just a couple but I think it's
because during that six seconds when
there's nothing you can do but wait
you're just sitting there saying you're
wasting my time and that's my most
precious thing right and then but it's
not only just is it slow it's like
there's nothing more frustrating to me
than like you're on that website you're
about to fill out the form you type in
all the fields you click submit and then
the next page comes out it says oh you
didn't fill this one thing you didn't
put dashes in the phone number and then
the whole form is empty you got to redo
it the website just wasted your most
precious ass at your time right so new
relics mission is to help give people
more precious moments in front of their
software and hopefully even time away
from the software more time with your
family or something like that instead of
waiting around for bad software so
that's why what we think we do matters
well you know something comes to M
that's excellent and we got some good
sound bites out of that didn't we I know
the editorial team's loveing that um the
mother of all software or the first
first world softw I love that H let's go
to strategy for a minute so because I've
heard you this has come up in class
before when you've come by it's not just
you celebrate innovation in technology
which I want to talk about but also
innovation in the business models on the
business side of things and so New Relic
is an instance of
that had to sell it didn't have to sell
but it made sense to sell my last
company at um um in' 06 and I I thought
deeply on why that was and it really
came down to the business model that was
a traditional enterprise software
companies enterprise software companies
license and maintenance enterprise
software companies you can spend 9 12
months with the customer and then they
sign up for a very large check um that
um and and and basically it's very hard
to predict when that customer is going
to say yes and and and usually after
they say yes it's another 90 days before
you actually get a contract out of them
so anyway that's a really painful
business model to to execute to because
it's hard to predict what the revenues
and it's very expensive to build out
that field presence so um uh when I
started New Relic I didn't want to be
purely dependent on just Enterprise
business and I didn't want it to be a
licensed business where um it was very
lumpy because it's really you know it's
hard to sleep at night if you don't know
whether or not especially in the last
seven days of the quarter where like 70%
of revenues could come in and uh and
those are paying salaries right so I
wanted a subscription business I wanted
a business where um How do you reach the
whole market and the way you do that um
I think in business software is you have
to build a product that's so simple so
easy to use that the customer can see
the value without the help of a
salesperson um and there's a lot of
effort that has to go into design and um
and thought about the onboarding process
that may seem obvious to to folks in
this room because of all the great
consumer products use but it's actually
pretty rare in Enterprise software um so
if you design a product with the
business model in line in mind it can
really just uh it can reduce your
distribution costs because now you know
we give out a t-shirt with data nerd on
it and somebody tries it out and they
fall in love and they want to become a
customer that compresses our sales cycle
dramatically um now we do have an
Enterprise business as well that does
have that traditional sales model but
it's great to have that balanced
subscription business of of of small
companies um that business model was by
Design but it started with the product
being engineered for the business model
you can't just glue the business model
you want to a product that isn't well
suited to it and that's why think the
incumbents are having trouble sort of
being uh being successful in the SAS
world the products aren't engineered for
for the kind of business model that I
was just
describing mind if I ask a little bit
about operations one one would be I'm
not a domain expert you can try or or
about the you know the other side so you
took on Venture Capital this time yeah
um given your successive Wy in the
network you could have stayed with
friends and family or you know why take
on traditional Venture Capital like uh
and even make one of them the chairman
of your firm Peter Fenton of Benchmark
he's the chairman of your firm he is and
uh he's he's my best friend I I I
couldn't respect anyone more as a
business partner as a person than Peter
um you know when I started New Relic I
really didn't know if it had the
potential to be a company that really
made sense for Venture funding I was
thinking maybe this is just a little
business that aspires to have maybe 5
million in ual subscriptions and you
know maybe um maybe we have half a dozen
employees that all just kind of check
email and all the checks rolled in that
was an interesting concept and Peter
completely disillusioned me of that um
by saying no there's there's an
opportunity to build a great company by
the way that idea you have is um it's
not going to be you just sitting in and
waiting for the checks to come in you're
going to be carrying the pager and
you're going to be having a much harder
life than you imagined so um Peter's
remarkably good at helping people aspire
to Greatness and do the do their do
their very best their full potential and
that's you know over a glass of very
nice wine he and I uh talked about
building a great company together in um
in late 07 early 08 um and uh um for
those you don't know I think Peter's
routinely in the top you know three to
four on the Midas list I think he's just
without question one of the greatest
Venture capitalists in in the world um
and uh and why do you say that when when
a venture capitalist is more than just
the money what what is he
provides well I think one of the things
is like he knows how to inspire
entrepreneurs to reach higher and he
does it in a way that is all about you
can do this like you know it's it's it's
it's in inspirational is the right word
I use he he um he'll he'll challenge me
but he'll always support support me as a
Founder um and my litmus test for
working with investors is um if you're
lucky enough to have term sheets from a
few investors um um you know what's more
important than the terms are the
likelihood that you're going to have a
really open and honest relationship and
a high trust relationship with that
investor and so um if if you're looking
at a term sheet what I'd recommend you
do is give yourself a gut check and ask
is this individual someone that I feel I
could come to very comfortably with bad
news because you will no doubt have bad
bad days bad weeks bad news to share
with your investers if you're going
through the uh the startup ride
everybody does so the question is are
you going to feel like hesitant you're
going to like kind of shape the message
to make sure that you know they don't
overreact or whatever are they going to
get too um to to just difficult to work
with or are they going to be
collaborative and help you solve
whatever problem needs to be solved that
gut check Peter like you resonates very
well with that and I'm also blessed to
have like Dan skolnick is another great
board member on my team I mean I've just
got great investors but they almost feel
like co-founders I mean given that you
were a solo founder which is unusual uh
they certainly the data know they they
almost become you say he's the best
friend that almost sounds like a
co-founder yeah they feel like you know
deep partners that um you know I can be
completely open and vulnerable with so
and the interesting thing about it is um
I feel like it works better for their
relationship with me too cuz I I you
know you can people are smart they know
when they're being played or managed or
like you know someone's trying to
represent themselves as being someone
they're not um and there's temptation to
do that when you feel like you've I
don't know you're you're def you got to
defend yourself or you don't have that
level of trust with person when you're
completely open and vul vulnerable with
your investors they draw themselves in
and really want to help you too and help
you grow and your company succeeds so
it's it has this kind of symbiotic
relationship and I'd say the same thing
with how with how you work with your
senior team as well well that caught me
out my eye I've got a couple of things
and then we'll open up the uh General
Q&A the other one is that you are known
at least on
Wikipedia source of all and we all know
yeah exactly as the coding CEO that's
like a cartoon character yeah the coding
coding CEO who still finds time to activ
in actively involved I mean there was
one post by someone uh that said You
code on Thursdays and Fridays well um
you still do that so let me tell you the
story about behind this so I um I
remember I had a meeting with Peter
Fenton um spring of 12 or so and I was
like he's on the board of Twitter I'm
like how on Earth does Jack he at the
time he was very active with both
Twitter and S running both and I said
how does he manage the time and he said
and he gave me some guidance and so it
starts with just thinking deeply what
what do you love to do that you think
can really move the needle for your
company um and then after you allocate
your time accordingly to to line up with
how can you be most effective with your
time allocation um then make sure you've
got the team to compliment where you're
not focusing your time but anyway um for
me I I love building software and I love
creating stuff and I wouldn't want it to
be interpreted that like you know only
the only new ideas come from me or
anything like that we've got amazing
Engineers that are capable of building
amazing software but I'm less grumpy
when I'm writing code you know my my
wife says when I come back from a coding
Retreat I'm a little happier a little
more sometimes a little zoned out
because I'm just so deep in the zone of
whatever I'm trying to create but but it
does bring me back to the Strategic
discussions I think with a different
perspective I'm a little bit more um um
I don't I don't get asmed in the details
and things like that so so anyway how I
allocate the time is I try uh four to
six times a year to have a full
uninterrupted week of code um I do it in
a remote place sometimes I have to
explain to my poor daughter Caitlyn over
here that Daddy's going to somewhere
like Cabo San Lucas and I bring a laptop
and a screen and I write code for a week
and I come back with a prototype and uh
and the poor Engineers need to somehow
take that and figure out how to make a
product out of it hey goofball um so
anyway uh and I try to do that four to
six times a year and the thing about it
is
um why does why why do I do this well my
rationale for it is most software
companies go through this Arc where the
the original idea the company was
founded on has a high growth curve the
company brings in mature management and
they kind of get good at Distributing
and selling and growing the top line and
you build this engine that gets really
good at that but it's very hard for the
company to come up with a second act a
new fundamental idea that's totally
totally new and disruptive um that that
goes beyond the first idea in fact I
don't think there's more than five
companies that have really done it well
uh you know Apple obviously did it very
well Microsoft did it well going from
the OS to Applications back in the 90s
um Oracle You could argue did it when
they went from database to um to apps um
now what all those companies have in
common is uh led by founder um very
product focused um and the founder was
so obsessed on product that like you
know you asked you so so I I created the
next uh product uh in January of uh 12
in my cabinet Tahoe um and uh I'm very
obsessed on it um and and so that's
that's our our next ACT and we think
it's 10 times bigger than our current
act so um I'm not saying it's going to
happen like 100% but I believe it will
and and and more importantly I believe
that we want to create the culture where
we're never just kind of satisfied with
what we've created in the past um uh we
care about all we just don't want to be
uh you know a noia are you a nerd uh
absolutely absolutely well because I ask
because if you go to the site and you
see that in in this part of the site
that talks about the company culture you
know the the the atmosphere and and the
philosophies of what it's like to work
at New Relic at there's a celebration of
the nerd I think you mentioned it we're
D and nerds so it it reflects you I mean
I think bit but yeah yeah there is like
you know we we we certainly love um you
know we love creating software we love
and we love um you know people who use
who really
just do incredible things with their
minds right um and um but I'd say the
other thing that's kind of important
about our culture is this focus on um
there's a warmth to the culture of our
company um you know I I hear this every
time people kind of visit the company
like you know just how they get treated
by no matter who they bump into and they
come across and I think that's on the
thing I want the culture most being
known for is like um people of working
at New Relic or or interacting with New
Relic because the people are sincere um
and uh um and I just as we grow I feel
like that's going to be important to
preserve and and make sure the culture
is a place where you know there's
there's a warmth and honesty and
integrity to the company wow thank you I
think that's a good way or a good point
to segue to questions from the audience
let's do this for a little bit what did
we not cover that you'd like to hear
something about or to amplify something
uh perhaps that we did right here so in
your experience um can
you sharing the benefits and drawbacks
of being a Founder versus a co-founder
can you repeat the questions so the
question was can I share the the
benefits or contrast being a Founder
versus a
co-founder well I I I've been sole
founder of both my companies
um
and it in some ways it's harder in some
ways it's easier obviously I mean it's
um when when you're Soul founder it's
very
lonely um my first company I was in a
little one-bedroom apartment in Santa
Cruz but fortunately it was like you
know when I really got just overwhelmed
I'd walk out and stare at the ocean and
recognize how much more there was the
world than whatever I was worried about
um but um the soul founder thing um the
reason why I'm a soul founder I think is
um I always draw these analogies with
between creating software companies and
creating music um and the reason why I
run off to go code is kind of like a
musician that just you know feels like
they've got one more album in them right
and so I'm like a singer songwriter I I
I I write the music and I perform it
right um and there are better virtuos
musicians that can play the panel better
than I might be able to play right or as
as like pure Engineers that really um
you know are up to speed on algorith or
something um uh but but but because I'm
writing the stuff that I'm conceiving of
um and I'm doing that kind of in that in
that kind of very isolated early stage
um I think there's just something in the
product that is harder to get now the
other analogy is lenon and McCartney
right so so there are these Duos that
create incredible products um and and I
and and I have a partner my CTO is
somebody that I go to Every time I have
an idea and he's my bounce you my my
soundboard and the person that um um you
know he's very good at at at telling me
no and and doing in a way that makes me
feel like boy is he ever right um and uh
um so I I do have that but I I just
liked at the very beginning just kind of
be um just like you know writing a novel
alone The Hermit in the woods kind of
thing without without um going crazy
hopefully so question in the very back
yeah thank you so uh one of the other
speakers in this series uh t uh
presented to us that uh he thought there
should be a national entrepreneurs day
especially engineering entrepreneurs
days because the tinkerers that add
value this way um at you know they add
tremendous value to the society but they
also take great risks and frequently
fail so I wonder if you can talk about
how the Innovation and the risk
associated with those Innovations in
your firm Dov tales with a society that
can be kind of hard on failure how that
works inside your uh your community uh
at New Relic and how it works between
New Relic and other
firms uh it's a it's a good question I
feel like
um yeah as a society um we you know
can't help but probably put too much
emphasis on the folks that happen to be
fortunate enough to have success um and
it's the same like but you to look at
that any like you know um think of how
many people are playing minor league
ball that never you know had their one
at bat in the majors or whatever right
you you can look in almost any domain
and just sort of see that and that's
kind of kind of natural um I if if there
is any celebrating going on um for for
entrepreneurship or anything like that
it should be
for um I think the joy of creating stuff
I'm a huge fan by the way of code.org
and just getting you know Hardy
partovi's project to get um I think
they're on their way to 100 million
people learning how to code and in
particular getting explain who they are
just a littleit so so code.org is this
remarkable project that that um anybody
can learn how to code in an hour um and
in particular and I think this is really
important getting more girls excited
about coding at a young age there's not
enough women in in software and I really
think that that ought to that ought to
change and the the and the best way I
know how to do it is to get girls at a
young age to do it um and so um I
remember Christmas of last
year um my daughter and her three
friends um were um at my cabin in Tahoe
was three days after Christmas there's a
room full of presents and there's four
girls fighting over three computers
because they all want to learn how to
code on code.org and that was the
coolest thing ever so um you know
encourage young girls well young people
or any anybody to to go to code.org and
just learn learn a bit more of that and
that's what I'd like to celebrate yeah
okay there was somebody in the middle
here did you oh yeah I was curious um
you could talk a little bit about
long-term strategy in this mobile
Enterprise space and then like a sub
question related to that looking at your
product I was curious um whether you're
going to go by way of like a Marketplace
kind of like Salesforce where people can
integrate into your product or have
people learn the neic query language oh
very good question can you restate that
just in case yeah I I hope I'm going to
answer the question the way you what
you're looking for but you're asking
about our long-term business strategy
um in particular about how um you know
are we going to have people build
applications on top of our our big data
database technology or is there going to
be a Marketplace or something like that
and how does mobile fit into it so let
me spend a little bit of time on this
thing that I created in the Tahoe cabin
a year ago two and a half nearly two
years ago now I started it
um totally don't invent you know not
invented here I in I reinvented the
wheel but I created a big data database
from scratch and um but I wanted to do
something that was high performance tune
for real-time analytics um and and
existing uh database Technologies were a
little too generic and so um they
couldn't wh do it a billion event query
in under a second on any attribute um um
so so that's what that's what we've
built and and the power of this is that
since we're collecting all this data
from software in real time we can answer
questions like how many people under 15
of looking at an item right now that
that signed up last week all the kind of
business questions that you want to know
what's going on in your software and and
and the cool thing is we've got this
Cloud database that um you don't need to
do anything just shove the data in you
don't need to worry about indexing or
configuring anything like that the point
is this is a very powerful technology
but upon which is we're in the like not
even the first inning of we we're you
know we've got this $40 billion big data
analytics opportunity and we've got a
really differentiated technology my
vision is at the moment and I'm working
on it but my best
I think our best path forward is to make
a platform out of that where our
customers can build applications on it
um in the cloud so if you want to build
an application for your support
organization to help support reps um
understand what the end customer's
experience is for a specific user um you
can build that app on top of the New
Relic data application platform you can
do it for salese for marketing people
inside your org My ultimate vision is I
want every knowledge worker to be a New
Relic data nerd using our analytics
products to so going Beyond just the
software developers and the people who
build software to everybody who has a um
some some some something to contribute
um as a knowledge worker um using big
data analytics that new Rel
provides right here um so most recently
you raised a lot of money from private
Equity why did you do that instead of
like the typical grou which is VC then
IPO right so the question was we
recently raised a large round and it was
uh private actually the the investors in
that round are large institutional funds
that typically invest in public
companies so um Fidelity and um tro
price and U Black Rock these are these
are folks that typically invest in in
public companies and what we found is or
what they've been seeing is um um for
certain occasions uh rarely they'll
they'll go into some private companies
that they see have you know potential to
be big important companies and they'll
kind of break their rule about being
only public investor
um and uh and and New Relic has
aspirations to be an independent company
for the long term and so what we want to
do was have an investor base that feel
like they're just at the beginning of
their Journey with New Relic unlike um
and I you know I believe my Venture
investors when they say they're they're
long New Relic too but Venture funds are
structured so that you know they're
they're they're in private companies so
so we wanted to bring in people who
think of New Relic as you know this very
early stage company that they want to
participate in for a very long period of
time and and so we we we went out to you
know the the top tier Public Market
investors and we were lucky enough to
put together a good round so that was a
$100 million round we closed last uh
last spring and our aspiration is to be
a public company and uh but that's just
a step along the
journey right here um hey would it be
possible to um get into the early days
of your of the founding of your first um
first first company how did you get
going how did you get the capital or the
sure resources so the question is how
tell me about the early days of my first
company that company also it's talked a
good bit about in this book by our
friend Professor werman Harvard but you
know give us the uh headin yeah the
early day of days of Wy as I said I was
an engineer I hadn't desire to start a
company and I I and I was a Java
developer and I was stuck with this
problem of my Java software worked in my
local environment when every time I ran
it in a remote environment it was broken
and I didn't know why and so I'm driving
down Highway 17 to my little apartment
in Santa Cruz and I'm thinking thinking
how do I solve this problem for myself
and this idea this of something called
bik code instrumentation a way to modify
the Java program without the person who
built the software needing to do
anything another program could make that
that software self- Diagnostic and I was
so excited about that idea being the
nerd that I am that I almost drove off
the road on 17 that would have been
early end to you know there would be no
ETL in 2014 so anyway uh by the time I
made to Santa Cruz I said I I I want to
start a company problem was I have I was
not from a family of means I had no
money but I was only 28 years old and so
I mean there wasn't much to lose so I
called up my parents and and they didn't
have any Capital invest but they had
seven friends who um each were willing
to put $5,000 in So within about a week
I had 35,000 of committed Capital well
that was infinite funds as far as I
concerned I could live forever on it so
so um I said of course I'll quit my day
job what's the downside side there's
none so I I I started W I worked on it I
remember Christmas day my parents
ripping me away from the computer cuz I
just about got the Prototype working
come on it's Christmas dinner Lou so all
right if if this progress bar makes it
across the end then it works and and so
that's what that's how it got started
and uh it turned into $100,000 of first
funding from you know people like the
Headmaster of my high school and other
sort of you know um they all made out
really well by the way um so um but uh
yeah I did hire my first employee for a
full year nobody would fund me because I
mean first of all this was 98 so I
wasn't doing shoelaces decom or anything
that was like public internet and like
anything public internet could funded
but something like I've got Java B code
Instrumentation Technology and no
capability to talk about that as a
business nobody wanted to fund that um
so but that was good because um the
bubble burst in 2000 and I hadn't raised
much money um so we didn't have a burn
rate or anything like that and and we
kind of of just got into our stride and
raised our first significant round uh in
2000 and and and then we were well
positioned to actually build a business
Lou I'm watching the clock because I
know uh we're I got a flight to catch
yeah you a flight to catch yeah but we
got one or how about one more over here
yeah I to ask more about the culture and
hiring you talked about like warmth and
kindness and you talked about like not
wanting like uh people who only care
about like the pot of gold at the end
and things like that how did you uh it
how did you make that culture and how
did you balance that with wanting to
hire strong uh being competitive and
hire yeah uh the question was about the
culture and building a warm culture how
do you go about building that and of
course you you want to build a
competitive company and you want to win
in your Marketplace and certainly those
those are important things in your Relic
as
well I think it's the same life skills I
mean like it's just how do you choose
your friends right I mean how do you get
to know people and you're like do I want
to spend time with them I we talk about
like one litness test is could you
imagine hopping in a car with this
person driving to La would you enjoy
that road trip or would you be like get
me out of the car right so um I was
fortunate enough early on in my in both
my companies to hire people I had deep
respect with I thought they were gifted
but they I thought they brought out the
best in me um and but I wanted to spend
time with them so you know you never
want kind of a marriage of convenience
where it's like you've got skills I need
I've got you know a company that could
help make you wealthy let's like work
together I mean like if that's how
making it happen then don't do it right
work with people that's going to bring
out the best in you they're going to be
dark days they're going to be
challenging days you want people that
you're like you're in it with together
um and uh and then you just keep
investing them the other thing I would
say that I don't think people do enough
of is they think of recruiting as all
right get someone to say yes get them to
join your company then Focus your
recruiting time on the next person keep
recruiting your people after they come
in what I mean by that is check in on
them 3 months after they've joined is
the company like you know are you loving
your job are you loving your Mondays is
this turning out the way you hoped is it
better than you hoped what what what is
about it that that you like you know
what can we do to make keep the company
special for people right so you want
people to feel valued right everybody
wants to feel valued no matter what you
do if you're a support rep if you're in
finance if you're in marketing you want
to feel like what you do matters and if
you feel like what you do matters then
it turns out you're pretty nice to other
people all right so it's it's all kind
of this it's all
intertwined please join me in thanking
[Applause]
l